primero de agosto de 2021 israel se
convertía en el primer país del mundo en
permitir una tercera dosis de la vacuna
contra el hobbit 19 y a partir del 21 de
diciembre también es el primer país en
autorizar esta vez una cuarta dosis he
dado la orden de preparar inmediatamente
a una cuarta vacuna incluso durante esta
ola como hicimos con el refuerzo durante
delta pretendemos ser activos e
innovadores y hacer todo lo posible para
ganar el mundo no seguirá la fecha del
comienzo de la vacunación para esta
cuarta dosis no se conoce todavía pero
si sus beneficiarios estará abierta para
los mayores de 60 años personas
inmunocomprometidas y el personal médico
el objetivo del gobierno israelí luchar
contra la variante omicron que se sigue
extendiendo en el país las autoridades
también anunciaron otra decisión los
niños que pertenecen a comunidades donde
la vacunación es escasa y la morbilidad
elevada tendrán que tomar sus clases en
casa este es el caso de los árabes
israelíes y también de los judíos
ultra-ortodoxos que están vacunados dos
veces menos que el resto de la población
no estoy en contra de la vacunación pero
tengo un poco de pereza
no quiero
probablemente iré a hacerlo pronto
las infecciones diarias son las mayores
desde octubre y más de 300 de los casos
en el país están vinculados con omicron
israel impuso nuevas restricciones de
viaje con el objetivo de prevenir más
casos y para evitar un nuevo
confinamiento a nivel nacional